[Musica]
Scusate che in casa ne ho tipo 5 non
sono abituata a parlare senza averne una
in funzione Allora buonasera io non so
cosa possa una ragazza di appena 20 anni
lasciare a voi pubblico per la maggior
parte adulto questa sera perché comunque
nella vostra vita avete già imparato
tanto però ci voglio provare
lo vedete questo pezzo Questo qui è un
pezzo stampato in 3D si tratta di
possiamo chiamarla una sorta di metafora
che ci servirà per questa sera ma poi la
vediamo meglio
Oggi siamo qui per parlare di vuoti e di
come colmarli
purtroppo non esiste una guida unica Ok
mi spiace servate qua per la guida Avete
sbagliato posto anche perché ognuno di
noi ha il suo vuoto da colmare C'è chi
può avere un vuoto di tipo fisico C'è
chi può avere un vuoto di tipo economico
chi magari un vuoto di tipo affettivo e
chi magari può averlo di tipo mentale
come nel mio caso anche se qualcuno ha
fermato che i problemi mentali in realtà
non risiedono nella mente ma risiedono
nel cervello e che sono quindi curabili
mandiamo con calma da piccola non capivo
tanto le cose sapete come sono i bambini
No ingenui al massimo e quando capitava
magari che mamma e papà litigavano cose
che accadono in qualsiasi famiglia io la
prima cosa che andavo a pensare è questa
ecco basta non si amano più abbastanza
tragica e adesso che ho un ragazzo ho
capito normale litigare in una coppia
che sia per chi ha cucinato meglio o che
sia per chi Magari ha programmato il
robot nel modo migliore come Nel nostro
caso Ecco però quando ero piccola oltre
ad essere tanto ingenua non sapevo
neanche esprimere esattamente le mie
emozioni e quando capitava magari che i
miei genitori litigavano e non sapevo
come esprimere le mie emozioni come
farli capire quello che io provavo e
allora io ho sempre avuto questa cosa
ovvero il fatto di essere una tipa molto
creativa quindi una volta dopo una
litigata mi ero chiusa nella mia
cameretta ho sempre avuto questa cosa
nei momenti di difficoltà mi chiudo
nella mia mente silenzio totale oppure
musica di sottofondo e do sfogo alla
creatività inizio a costruire Ecco
quella volta avevo creato questo
si tratta di un piccolo cuore rosso
fatto di mattoncini che però dietro
trova un altro piccolo cuore nero Ecco
avevo spiegato così ai miei genitori
come mi sentivo quando loro litigavano E
sostanzialmente questo piccolo cuore
nero che si trova dietro Quello rosso è
in grado di impossessarsi del Cuoricino
rosso e a volte di farlo suo
Ecco di impossessarsi del Cuoricino
rosso a partire esattamente dal centro
più o meno in questo modo Ecco io avevo
spiegato Così come mi sentivo i miei
genitori un piccolo cuore rosso con una
piccola parte più scura però il
particolare gli avevo anche detto
L'importante è che quella parte più
scura non diventi troppo grande perché
poi sei diventa troppo grande è la fine
Può esistere un po' di odio nelle cose
L'importante è che non sia troppo che
non sia eccessivo bisogna anche però
capire cosa significa troppo eccessivo
Qual è quella linea che non bisogna
superare
Ecco io ho avuto modo purtroppo di
provare altri tipi di odio ve li
racconto qua che abbiamo abbastanza
tempo quindi ce la faccio ancora non so
quanti di voi mi conoscevano già prima
di trovarmi qua sul palco io faccio
quella nuova professione chiamata
influencer Ok quelli che fanno video sui
social è un lavoro è un lavoro ed è un
lavoro che comunque mi ha permesso di
essere qua quindi anche un bel lavoro Il
problema è che per quanto sia un bel
lavoro che ti dà tantissime gioie nella
realtà dei fatti ti dà anche tanto odio
Ecco non so se avete mai sentito parlare
di hater Ok le persone Quelle che
insultano online così che Voi direte Ma
cosa ci hanno le persone da prendere
solo con una ragazza che di vent'anni
che parla di tecnologia perché ecco la
cosa più comune e so che adesso non ci
crederete ma vi giuro esiste veramente è
questa sei donna
Sì grazie lo so di essere donna Cioè mi
vedo anch'io da sola no no intendo che
tu sei donna fai cose da maschio io non
imparerò mai quelle cose fatte da una
donna Ok va bene va bene Il problema è
qui direte Vabbè è un odio Stupido più
che stupido possiamo dire ignorante ok
Però il problema è che adesso che ho
imparato come sopportarlo quell'odio Non
mi fa niente ai tempi Però all'inizio
era un odio che dava comunque fastidio
per quanto fosse ignorante Ecco io ho
avuto modo di provare anche un altro
tipo di odio un altro tipo di odio
sempre stupido è fatto dei ragazzini non
so cioè Penso che tutti noi da piccoli
abbiamo fatto degli errori No non credo
che esista qualcuno che non abbia mai
fatto degli errori in vita sua Ecco a me
era capitato quando ero alle medie di
aver trovato un gruppo di compagni a cui
non stavo molto simpatica perché ero
brava a scuola
più o meno la scena era questa
professoressa dalle verifiche prendo la
verifica arriva il compagno mi guarda
ogrei quanto hai preso guarda ho preso 9
Caspita però che fatica per quel 9 Cioè
quanto avrei studiato ma in realtà ho
studiato una mezz'oretta ieri sera non è
che ci ho messo così tanto tempo dama tu
mi stai mentendo Ecco il problema è che
io ho sempre avuto questa cosa che sono
sempre stata brava a scuola e
soprattutto nelle materie che mi
piacevano tipo tecnologia per dire E non
ho mai fatto fatica a me bastava magari
stare attenta durante le ore di lezione
per fare la verifica la settimana dopo è
una grandissima fortuna lo ammetto Il
problema è che quando sei in una classe
di 20 persone e in 19 la vedono come
quel tuo compagno e tu sei l'unica
leggermente diversa capisci che forse il
problema sei tu inizia a capire che
forse ho a pensare che forse hai
qualcosa che non va Cos'è la cosa più
semplice mentire Ah no guarda per quel 9
no ha una fatica ieri neanche sono
riuscita a mangiare perché no non ce la
potevo fare ero in ansia non trovo tempo
Ok inizia a mentire Il problema è che
metti una volta 22 23 24 e poi piano
piano inizia a perdere te stessa Ecco io
poco alla volta stavo creando dentro di
me un vuoto sempre più grande da colmare
che però non sapevo come colmarlo perché
non sapevo Quale era il mio particolare
qual era quel problema che poteva avere
Allora Furia del passare degli anni ho
deciso di parlarne con qualcun' Anche
perché io di sta cosa ci stavo davvero
male di parlarne con qualcuno ho deciso
di parlarne col prete del paese il preti
sono quelle persone meravigliose che
sanno tutto di tutti e non dicono mai
niente datemi torto ma è sempre così ne
parlo col prete del paese Dona
Alessandro donale per gli amici li
spiego i miei problemi la sua risposta
Guardati un film
scusa devo dire io c'ho un grandissimo
problema che mi sta friggendo da diversi
anni E tu sai dirmi Solo questo vabbè oh
guardiamo Los film Se succede
fidiamoci Del Prete vado a vedere questo
film Il film si chiamava gifted il dono
del talento parla di una bambina di 7
anni che studia in università Sì nelle
ultime scene Si vede che la bambina
studia in università una bambina
brillantissima con un talento immenso
per la matematica una scarsa interazione
col gruppo dei pari e non deve
correggere il professore Quando sbaglia
la lavagna Almeno così le diceva lo zio
e così m'han detto i miei genitori per
vent'anni Ecco questo bambino per la
prima volta Vedendola in quel film mi
ero ritrovata adesso uguale a qualcuno
cioè io finalmente in quel momento mi
sentivo capita da qualcuno Ecco il
problema è che cosa c'è cosa ci sta
bambina mi sono informata e Questa
bambina assomiglia un po' a Sheldon
Sheldon Cooper quello di Big Bang Theory
non so quanti di voi hanno visto la
serie solo che Sheldon alla Asperger che
ha un autismo ad alto funzionamento
invece questa bambina ha una differenza
da Sheldon non ha l'asperger E lì cosa
c'ha Ecco vai a cercare inizia Cerca
descrizione titoli riviste e articoli
tutto quello che puoi trovare fino ad
arrivare a capire che la parola gifted
che è il titolo del film non significa
dono regalato quando io pubblico una
storia su Instagram per dire che
un'azienda mi ha regalato qualcosa
significa una neuro divergenza che in
italiano detta più semplice si chiama
plusdotazione con le traduzioni facciamo
schifo Ma questo lo sapevamo già Ecco si
tratta di una neuro divergenza anche qui
voi Mi direte cos'è la neuro divergenza
Scusa Ecco facciamola facile rubo l'idea
che mi ha dato una bambina che ho
incontrato si tratta di una
caratteristica stanzialmente una
caratteristica una caratteristica che
quando si trova il soggetto plusdotato
si manifesta con un quoziente
intellettivo superiore alla media stiamo
parlando di oltre il 130
e assieme al quoziente intellettivo
superiore alla media si hanno per
l'appunto è una capacità logica Maggiore
bravura a scuola noi a scuola e poca
interazione col gruppo dei pari Cinque
Sensi Più sviluppati tante altre
caratteristiche che non sto qua a
raccontarvi perché se no non mi basta il
tempo Ecco avevo finalmente trovato
qualcosa Finalmente riuscivo a capire
qualcosa Il problema che a furia di
cercare mi ero accorta che in Italia
purtroppo non se ne parla e quindi
online non si trovava nulla allora cosa
ti fai Ti fai a materiale estero vado a
cercare ti informi sempre di più e
inizio piano piano a capire a ritrovarmi
a capire che quello che io stavo
leggendo in poche parole era tipo la mia
vita Ok rileggevo i miei 18 16 anni di
vita a quel tempo
Poi dato che io sono una tipa molto
pratica se non ce l'ho scritto nero su
bianco non mi fido Allora deciso dopo la
maturità di andare a farmi valutare vado
faccio il test faccio valutare risultato
133 Plus dotata in quel momento tutto è
andato a posto Tutto magicamente nel mio
cervello 18 anni passati con il dubbio
di quale problema io potessi mai avere
era andato a posto Ecco era andato a
posto come se fosse un puzzle o come se
fosse questo pezzo che è stato appena
stampato davanti ai vostri occhi ovvero
questa piccola hit del terriccio che
doveva essere di colore rosso ma mi è
arrivata la bobina del colore sbagliato
ma quella è un'altra grande storia ecco
Era finalmente andato a posto tutto
però poi succedeva è successa un'altra
cosa c'era un altro problema perché se
no la vita è troppo facile no altro
problema quando sono andata a chiedere
di fare il test la prima cosa che la
psicologa mi ha detto è stata ma tu lo
stai facendo per te stesso oppure per
marciarci sui social perché dovete
sapere che è raro farsi valutare in età
adulta e lì per gli ero rimasta un po'
spiazzata non riuscivo a capire però
adesso che è passato oramai quasi due
anni riesco a capire qual era la sua
affermazione perché più o meno la scena
che capita è questa Ciao Piacere sono
Greta sono Plus dotata Ciao
Cosa significa significa che ho il
quoziente intellettivo superiore alla
media Quindi stai dicendo che sei più
intelligente di me no non sto dicendo
che sono più intelligente di te dico
solo che ho il quoziente intellettivo e
sostanzialmente succede questa cosa che
è abbastanza brutta immaginatela detta
sui social dove una sola parola può
creare panico totale Ok allora per quel
motivo avevo deciso di non parlarne
quindi dirlo solamente ai miei familiari
Però il problema è che gli ero ritornata
come alle medie che mentivo quando
prendevo un bel voto cosa succede
succede che passato un anno mi ero
stufata di nascondere questa mia
particolarità e ho deciso di farci un
video perché ti lavoro Faccio quello io
faccio video faccio video certo
tecnologici di stampa 3D di robotica
quello che volete ma faccio video faccio
informazioni faccio tutorial modo più
semplice per parlarne fare un video di
informazione su questa cosa perché come
vi ho detto prima in Italia non se ne
parla pubblico un video esattamente un
anno dopo il test nel giro di poche ore
ottiene 10.000 visualizzazioni 10.000
sono 10 volte la capienza di questo
teatro Noi siamo dentro in 400
moltiplicatevi per due moltiplicatevi
per 10
Ecco in un colpo 10.000 visualizzazioni
e adesso il video sta oltre le 140.000
non è le visualizzazioni poco incontrano
Anche perché sinceramente avevo fatto
senza aspettative quel video La cosa che
però più mi ha lasciato affascinata è il
fatto che dopo aver pubblicato il video
mi sono arrivati una Maria di commenti
da persone da tutta Italia che mi hanno
scritto
ringraziandomi perché grazie a quel mio
piccolo video fatto così a casissimo
loro avevano finalmente scoperto un
qualcosa che magari si portavano dietro
da tanti anni Erano finalmente riusciti
a colmare quel vuoto che anche loro si
portavano avanti davvero da tantissimi
anni Ecco io non so cosa possa una
ragazza di 20 anni insegnarvi stasera ma
se c'è una cosa che voglio lasciare è il
fatto che non sia mai troppo piccoli per
fare qualcosa
[Applauso]